Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Hasta cuánto puedes contar con los dedos?
Parece una pregunta
con una respuesta obvia.
Después de todo, la mayoría
tenemos 10 dedos,
O, para ser más precisos,
ocho dedos y dos pulgares.
Esto nos da un total de 10 dígitos
en nuestras dos manos,
que usamos para contar hasta 10.
No es casualidad que los 10 símbolos que
usamos en el sistema de numeración moderno
se llamen dígitos también.
Pero esa no es la única manera de contar.
En algunos lugares, es costumbre
contar hasta 12 con una sola mano.
¿Cómo?
Bueno, cada dedo se divide
en tres secciones,
y tenemos un indicador natural
para indicar cada una, el pulgar.
Eso nos da una forma fácil de contar
hasta 12 con una mano.
Y si queremos contar más alto,
podemos usar los dígitos de la otra mano
para contar la cantidad de doces,
hasta cinco grupos de 12, o 60.
Mejor aún, usemos las secciones
de la segunda mano
para contar 12 grupos de 12,
hasta 144.
Eso es una gran mejora,
pero podemos contar más alto encontrando
más partes contables en cada mano.
Por ejemplo, cada dedo tiene
tres secciones y tres pliegues
un total de seis cosas contables.
Ahora podemos contar
hasta 24 en cada mano,
y usar la otra mano para marcar
grupos de 24
y eso nos da 576.
¿Podemos contar más alto?
Parece que hemos alcanzado el límite
de partes diferentes de los dedos
que podemos contar con precisión.
Así que pensemos algo diferente.
Una de nuestras mejores
invenciones matemáticas
es el sistema de notación posicional,
donde la colocación de símbolos permite
diferentes magnitudes de valor,
como en el número 999.
Aunque se use el mismo símbolo tres veces,
cada posición indica un orden de magnitud.
Así podemos usar el valor de posición en
los dedos para batir el récord anterior.
Olvidémonos de las secciones
de los dedos ahora
y veamos el caso más simple de tener
solo dos opciones por dedo,
arriba y abajo.
Esto no nos permitirá representar
potencias de 10,
pero es perfecto para el sistema de conteo
que usa potencias de dos,
también conocido como binario.
En binario, cada posición duplica
el valor de la anterior,
así que podemos asignar
a los dedos valores de uno,
dos,
cuatro,
ocho,
y así hasta 512.
Y cualquier número entero positivo,
hasta cierto límite,
puede expresarse como suma
de estos números.
Por ejemplo, el número siete
es 4 + 2 + 1
y lo podemos representar
levantando estos tres dedos.
Mientras tanto, 250 es
128 + 64 + 32 + 16 + 8 + 2.
¿Cuán alto podemos llegar ahora?
Ese sería el número con los
10 dedos levantados: 1023.
¿Es posible contar más alto?
Depende de tu destreza.
Si puedes doblar los dedos hasta la mitad,
eso nos permite tres estados diferentes:
bajo,
medio,
levantado.
Pero puedes contar usando
un sistema posicional de base 3,
hasta 59 048.
Y si puedes doblar los dedos
en cuatro partes diferentes o más,
puedes contar más alto incluso.
Ese límite depende de ti,
y de tu propia flexibilidad e ingenio.
Incluso con los dedos
en solo dos posibles estados,
ya estamos trabajando
de manera bastante eficiente.
De hecho, las computadoras están
basadas en el mismo principio.
Cada microchip consta de diminutos
interruptores eléctricos
que pueden encender o apagar,
es decir que la base 2 es su forma
predeterminada de representar números.
Y así como podemos usar este sistema para
contar más de 1000 solo con los dedos,
una computadora puede realizar
miles de millones de operaciones
con solo contar unos y ceros.